so when it comes to the first
presidential debate only Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump the two most hated
presidential candidates in recorded
history will be allowed to participate
here are four good reasons by Gary
Johnson the libertarian candidate for
president who is also a former two-term
governor of New Mexico should be allowed
to participate and here's a bone two
supporters of the Green Party's
candidate Jill Stein at least a couple
of these apply to her as well the
Commission on Presidential Debates which
was created by the Republican and
Democratic parties in 1987 says
participants must average 15 percent in
five polls they choose the Y 15 percent
if you're going to insist on a polder of
a number five percent makes far more
sense that's the number you need to hit
to receive federal matching funds and
it's also the level that most states
insist on for a party to receive major
party status and thus not have to jump
through a bunch of ballot access hoops
in every election according to Real
Clear Politics latest round up of
national polls Johnson is at eight point
six percent there will be a job sucking
sound going south that's higher than
what independent candidate Ross Perot
was at in 1992 when he was invited to
the presidential debates
Johnson is on the ballot in all 50
states so he can theoretically win the
election but more realistically he will
totally influence the outcome in fact a
recent state-by-state poll had the guy
in double digits in 42 states and at 15
percent or better in 15 of those what
the hell is going on when a figure who
will be on every Americans ballad isn't
given a shot to make his case on the
same stage as the Republican and the
Democrat according to Gallup 60% of us
say that Democrats and Republicans do
such a bad job that a third major party
is needed to represent our views at the
ballot box just 38 percent say the Dems
and reps are getting the job done I
think it's despicable here's a charming
bit of video from 2000 when the debate
Commission announced its 15% rule for
the first time Donald Trump himself
argued forcefully that the Reform Party
candidate Pat Buchanan the Green Party
candidate Ralph Nader and others should
be allowed to participate in the
presidential debates I just think it's
unfair the regardless of that to have
such a high standard higher criteria for
a party that's a legitimate party that
has a substantial amount of federal
funding that's recognized and where at
some point during this process
somebody's gonna be in all 50 states
very unfair he said they were only being
excluded because Republican George W
Bush and Democrat Al Gore were scared of
competition Minnesota's then Governor
Jesse Ventura introduces Trump by
calling the exclusion of third parties
despicable and noting that if he hadn't
been allowed to debate Democrats Hubert
Humphrey the third and Republican Norm
Coleman he never would have become
governor of Minnesota to the best of my
judgment
and abilities so help me God so help me
God
questions coming from strangers for
reason TV I'm Nicolas be